Let's have a little bit
more fun with operators.
We'll start by using just
literals to demonstrate,
but these operators work with variables,
constants, and
if you're accessing struct property
values like we've seen so far.
First let's add two numbers together and
as you expect, 5 + 3 = 8.
We can subtract two numbers.
And notice if we use subtraction
between these two numbers, 5 and 2.5,
where one is a floating point number,
we get a floating point result.
And that's because Swift compiler's
smart enough to know the difference
between subtracting two integers here
and getting an integer result and
subtracting out a floating point value
here to compute a floating point result.
We'll go ahead and do the same for
multiplication and
division but here's something
that's a little bit interesting.
How come when we divide 5 by 3,
we just get the value of 1?
Well since the Swift compiler knows
both these literal values are integers,
when it performs the division it
does not include the decimal part.
Instead, it truncates
the decimal part and
leaves you with this whole value of 1.
Now let's see what happens with
the dreaded divide by 0 case.
It looks like the Swift compiler
is smart enough to know
that this is a divide by 0 and
it can't execute this.
But enough with these literals,
let's try some actual variables now.
I created these ahead of time so
I'm just going to paste them in, and
we have a variable for
the value 5, 3, and 0.
And now we're trying to do the same
5 / 0, or a divide by 0 case,
but what's going on this time?
Last time the Swift compiler was
able to detect the divide by 0.
Well this time since
we're using a variable,
the Swift compiler cannot
automatically detect the issue.
Instead, the playground file tries to
run this code, and as you can see,
the execution's interrupted
because it can't execute this.
And we can tell that the execution of
the playground stopped, because if I try
to go a line below and do anything, we
can see that it never reaches this line.
It stops right here.
So let's just remove this.
And comment this line out.
There's one more operator I want to
introduce which belongs with add,
subtract, multiply and divide and
that's the remainder operator,
also called the modulus operator.
Many times you'll hear it called mod for
short.
The mod operator allows us
to perform division and
then return only the remainder.
And this operator's really useful
when determining multiples or
if a number's even or odd.
By the way, the modulus
operator is the percent sign,
and we can see if we mod 10 by
the number 2, the remainder is 0.
So we know that 10's an even number.
Let's try this with an odd number.
And in this case, cause the result is 1,
we know that the number is odd.
But you don't just have to do even and
odd, let's try and example for say,
multiples of 5.
We know that 5 is a multiple of 5,
but 6, 7, and 8 are not, and
we can see the reminders here.